[Music]
Petrus macorís is the most
internationally renowned Greek author of
our time I'll be talking with him about
the Greeks the Germans and Europe a warm
welcome to the DW interview mr.
marquales
Davy interviewer mark thank you thank
you for inviting me
Zia gasps I'm glad you could join us
ladies and gentlemen my name is Thomas
pan Oh Marcus
mr. marker is the story of your life is
in itself material for a novel you were
born to Greek Armenian parents in
Istanbul and attended an Austrian
secondary school to learn German with so
many cultures don't you ever get mixed
up yeah as oh and does he die on that
day Ilana well [ __ ] the fact that I
learned German was my father's wish I
had no say in the matter
he decided that I absolutely had to
learn German I went to secondary school
in 1949 right when West Germany's
economic miracle was getting underway
and my father was absolutely convinced
that German would rise to become the
international language of business so I
had to learn German because his second
wish was that I should one day take over
his company in Istanbul what did you
fear many he was mistaken on both counts
but I did learn German yep
are they have dr. Keller been manzil
parents always say they love all their
children equally but that's generally
not true they usually have a favorite of
your many cultural influences which one
is your favorite you have it if you
can't does well I've often said that I
feel rooted in German culture and I feel
more at home in German literature than
an ancient Greek literature
I'm not saying Greek but ancient Greek
identity guy tricked laughing I have
more knowledge of German classicism then
I have of the literature of ancient
Greece then no pecan doesn't donate to a
wider audience for your
three novels featuring inspector
Jarritos who solves his cases in unusual
ways and you introduced him to read us
on your book tours also here in Germany
as you did today
fell back near Stuttgart what reaction
do you get from a German audiences what
are the fans say what do they find so
appealing about the inspector I thought
that call me sir
I'd say the inspector has already
established himself as a favorite
character in Germany I say that with
great satisfaction and in fact the
Germans are always coming up to me and
asking if a new Harry Joe's story is in
the works will he continue well they
skip Dinah gutsy and Edison and there's
a very interesting difference between
readers in the north and readers in the
south in southern Europe and South
America the readers identify with the
entire family not just where the
inspector I've encountered Spaniards and
Argentinians
who come up to me and tell me the
inspectors wife Andre any reminds them
of their own mother in Germany interest
is centred on the inspector first the
family comes after Easter
so a Steinman that comes on the Familia
forked yoga your episodes and a number
of your books are set against the
backdrop of the Greek debt crisis you
saw that coming very early on how right
at the beginning but boy because you'd
studied economics and you one can't
spend more than what earns it may be
that economics played some part in it
but it was more the rage against the
Greek politicians in the beginning that
politicians told the Greeks yes we will
have to take some steps and make a few
reforms but it's not that bad
it'll be over in two years but I knew it
wouldn't be over in two years and I was
furious because they had lied to the
people
in addition speaking so the Greeks
didn't have a chance to prepare
themselves and build up any defenses
that would have enabled them to handle
the crisis their system also banned
after Banda meet scimitar Chris I'm
geeking hmm
well description as the crisis has
dragged on unresolved many Germans view
of the Greeks has changed they say we
keep paying Athens bills and nothing
changes and now a majority of Germans
favor Greece exiting the euro can your
German soul relate or do you see that as
unjust I know most migrants I have to
see this very clearly I'd say just the
same in Germany or in Greece for what's
happened in Greece the Greeks themselves
are to blame symbol is that there's no
two ways about it
one is 8 then ah we've been making very
serious mistakes since the 1980s in
Greece D is a creature Fela and these
very serious mistakes that led Greece to
build up let's call it a fictional
wealth right it was all a fiction that's
a Alice Zhang veer 15 a fun credit
amount of credit on reddit or on
subsidies it started with subsidies I'll
be it but now I have something to tell
the Germans
it was clear long ago and they knew by
the 1980s that these subsidies were not
being invested in ways that they were
supposed to be invested for example
agricultural subsidies intended to allow
farmers to purchase new models of
equipment they were just divvied up and
I have to tell you everyone knew it and
everyone kept silent and looked away the
Germans do Encanto been a central
problem with the Greek crisis is that
tax revenues are still not coming in
like they showed in your novel
termination you put forward a rather
drastic solution which is to kill
wealthy tax dodge
Grieg's boom blinked and after the third
murder the fourth victim in line pays up
a pretty drastic method but
unfortunately the greeks together with
the europeans came up with an even more
drastic method which was to raise the
income tax to 29% that's not just crazy
I'm sorry but it's plain stupid in the
meantime some 17,000 small and medium
sized Greek businesses have relocated
either to Bulgaria or deciphers and
they're expected to pay income tax in
Greece they're located in Bulgarian
paying 6% and in Cyprus they're paying
10% and the Greeks know the Germans know
and the Europeans know it'll never work
with 29% and the Greek economy is on its
knees Borden youth unemployment is
horrific overall unemployment - how does
that affect Greeks and Germans
you can't endure sovaldi Greek only on
the one hand the Greeks don't seem to
understand the Germans really want to do
something and they're trying to do so
within the framework of the European
Union than the other hand it'll pass
the Germans are refusing to see that
with the death of medium-sized
businesses the situation in Greece is in
a dead-end an important meeting stunt
and very cancelled this misunderstanding
reflects a collision of two conflicting
mentalities the Germans with a passion
for security financial savings a
building loan contract at life insurance
and the Greeks who they accused of
putting off until tomorrow what they
should do today rice in your diet eat
that's what you're citing is reasons I
think the Greeks would see it
differently sonica be good eating
when I first got to know the Greeks in
the 1950s they were much poorer than
they are today Adam and yet they were
happy they nevertheless enjoyed life
well there were four people four but
they were a people with a high cultural
evoke I described that as the poverty
culture poverty with culture I I would
be cooked or vast deal ID degree
committed this what the Greeks did not
have was a culture of wealth the captain
kind of had no idea that wealth also has
its own culture do God they had never
seen it would serve our twelfth I'm mad
right this was primarily because as part
of the Ottoman Empire
Oh the Greeks never experienced the
Enlightenment me not even the French
Revolution or the revolutions that came
after in the 1930s and 40s they were
still completely alienated from the
developments taking place in European
society Freddie and friend it's what
gets and now the crisis is going into
its eighth year with no end in sight in
one of your novels you have Greece
returning to the drachma is that your
own position it's a hook it's just yeah
yes but another solution is coming now
you'll have to have a little more
patience doesn't give us a hint the new
novels coming out it provides a solution
whether you like it is another question
but it provides a solution does is don't
lie today unfortunately our time is
running out interview my CC you know I
have one last thing to tell you one last
sentence I don't find me but not for me
but a quote from Hyneman he once said
optimism is just a lack of information
mangle informatin
the lessons and these are at this point
I'd like you to complete three sentences
Tabata and ZD dragons to me personally
Europe means guns peasant ish the
greatest earth their humanistic endeavor
that's ever been undertaken in Europe a
laser pointer number order mine Kamiya
my protagonist detective Kostas Jarritos
doesn't think too much of women because
colony also feel violet by yeah because
his wife just gives him the runaround
despite all the tensions between Germans
and Greeks will be overcome when in the
tensions between Germans and Greeks will
be overcome when both sides understand
that these two countries peoples and
States built a very close friendship
after the Second World War I danced
Angus Froy and I should remember that
debate in Kafka Baran was a mission to
the plaintiff Pedro's marker is many
thanks